ja dann möchte auch ich mich ganz
herzlich bedanken und für die Einladung
und auch für die Organisation von diesem
Symposium an die Münchner oder sie
anders in München oder dozenieren der
Netzwerk mein Name ist Adam Thomas ich
bin Sprachwissenschaftler von der
Fakultät 13 LMU und beschäftige mich
eigentlich mit verschiedenen Dingen aber
heute möchte ich über die
Selbstbewertung der Lehre sprechen
[Musik]
ja hier eine kurze Gliederung zu den
einfahren Punkten aber man Fokus richtet
sich eigentlich auf die Selbstreflexion
der Lehre und die
eigene Lehre zu reflektieren mit Peer
Reviews und natürlich auch guten
Kommentaren zudem Review und allgemeinen
ähm ja äh Themen die wir schon in den
letzten Vorträgen gehört haben da kommen
wir noch mal zurück aber hat mir sehr
gut getan so ein bisschen Auftrieb und
auf ihn zu bekommen grundsätzlich
vielleicht ein paar interessante Blicke
die wir richten können wäre die
Außenperspektive
natürlich auch der lehrbericht der elemo
München über verschiedene Fächer ich
habe mich auf die Germanistik und
Fakultät 13
sprachwissenschaftliteraturwissenschaften
konzentriert und die Grundfrage oder der
das Kernstücke sollte eigentlich sein
was ist ein Spektrum der guten Lehrenden
wie sehen guten Lehrende aus was ist
eigentlich dort zu erwarten wie können
wir das verbessern oder im proven auf
neudeutsch gesagt diese Fragen oder wie
auch andere Fragen die stelle ich mir
seit längerem ich bin seit 20 Jahren
Sprachwissenschaftler und Dozent und
Übersetzer und Dolmetscher aber
natürlich schwingen diese Fragen immer
wieder mit wie bin ich wie gut komme ich
rüber wie interessant ist mein
Forschungsgebiet wie kann ich das
Verpacken wie verhalte ich mich im
Gartenzimmer und vielleicht um auch den
Fokus auf unser Thema zulegen wie ist
mein Zeitgefühl was sagen die Kollegen
oder auch die und über mein
Zeitmanagement und das sind die Fragen
die mich beschäftigen und zu denen ich
dann auch ein paar
Ansätze Vorbringen möchte
grundsätzlich eine kurze Einführung ist
ein sehr schönes Buch und ich bin über
das Lesen dieses Buches einfach mal in
auf diese Fragen gekommen was bedeutet
eigentlich Zeit und eigentlich ist Zeit
wie auch Albert Einstein und wir alle
schon ein bisschen relative Geschichte
aber Zeit und letztendlich auch wir sind
nur im Austausch und Vergleich mit
anderen messbar oder vergleichbar und da
ist mir dieser initiale Gedanke gekommen
wie bin ich denn eigentlich im Vergleich
zu anderen Dozierenden zu anderen
Studierenden wie freundlich trete ich
auf wie gut sind meine Inhalte verpackt
und natürlich auch und wieder bei der
Zeit zu bleiben wie gut kommt man mit
der Zeit voran wie kann man die Zeit so
nützen ausnutzen dass sie für die
Studenten auch gebrauchbar ist dass die
Inhalte nicht zu viel und nicht zu wenig
nicht so schnell und nicht so langsam
ankommen aber für die die wollen
wirklich eine sehr sehr tolle Lektüre
wie die Geschichte der Zeitung zu den
Reviews vielleicht ein paar
Streiflichter was uns allen auch bekannt
ist aber
interessanterweise im 17 Jahrhundert mit
der Gründung von den Akademien und in
den Wissenschaften die sich dann
etabliert haben war auch immer das
Bestreben nach einheitlichen Kriterien
und daher kamen auch die Idee wie man
ein Review startet oder was es überhaupt
bedeutet verbunden auch eng mit
wissenschaftlichen Zeitschriften mit der
Bewertung und Auswertung auch gottfried
Wilhelm Leibnitz wird das so angedichtet
dass er wahrscheinlich so der erste war
der das aus der Taufe gehoben hat
zumindest auf diesen Breitengraden und
was das sehr interessant ist natürlich
auch zu verstehen warum hat man das
gemacht welche Ziele waren dahinter
herauszufinden wie andere denken über
das was ich eigentlich schon habe oder
ich weiß was ich über etwas zu sagen
habe wie denken andere darüber zu dem
Thema oder allein zu der Bedeutung des
Wortes interessant eigentlich sprechen
wir von gleich sind von Kollegen auf der
gleichen Ebene daher so müsste man Fokus
wie vielleicht die Studierenden über
mich denken oder andere die mir anhören
das ist in Ordnung das weiß ich ein
bisschen oder langsam schon immer mehr
und mehr aber mich wieder wirklich
interessieren wie ich vor Kollegen
Kolleginnen auftrete und wie allgemein
diese Strukturen die ich aufbaue die ich
anbiete sie verständlich sind
grundsätzlich hat sich dann im Laufe der
Zeit auch natürlich die Funktion von
diesen Peer Reviews entwickelt da gibt
es alles mögliche aber im Grunde
genommen waren das wissenschaftliche
Standards Begutachtungen oder Werkzeuge
zur Qualitätskontrolle Zensur von
Büchern also im Laufe der Zeit haben
sich diese Kriterien so etabliert dass
man sie heute ich glaube gar nicht
wegdenken kann das war auch mein
abstract meine Idee dass man eigentlich
wenn man
Einreichungen hat und verschiedene
Zeitschriften anschreibt oder irgendwie
auch in einem Symposium Kongress etwas
vorgetragen hat danach wird dir ein
Review von den Einreichungen so völlig
verständlich dass es durchgezogen wird
meine Idee wäre vielleicht könnte man
nicht den könnte ich mir vorstellen dass
man mich und meinen Vortragsstil an der
univers geht die Lehre nach 15 bis 20
Jahren in der Lehre sage ich ich weiß
einiges ich kann einiges wirklich sehr
gut bei manchen Sachen bin ich mir
vielleicht gar nicht so sicher aber wie
ich so bin ich habe meine Meinung dazu
was mich aber interessieren würde wie
die anderen darüber reden und was sie
darüber meinen also zu den Standards und
den den Perspektiven von Imperium ich
glaube das ist hier allen bekannt aber
es gibt sehr viele Literatur sehr viel
Material die einfache Begutachtung
doppelte Begutachtung offene
Begutachtung wo man eigentlich dann weiß
wer von wem was begutachtet ich glaube
das gehört zu unserem senal und das
wissen wir ich ich hatte die Frage
gestellt können wir das Anwenden nicht
nur für die Artikel für die
Einreichungen sondern auch für unsere
Lehre für das was wir eigentlich machen
grundsätzlich also auch hier wirklich
ein paar gute Literatur Hinweise
vielleicht der Fokus auf die
Handreichungen zur online-lehre vom
Profil ich habe mit ihnen sehr viel
zusammengearbeitet ist sehr
empfehlenswerte Sache und man kann mit
ihnen Termine vereinbaren sich anmelden
Themen Vorschläge machen und oder auch
die kommen dann in die Lehre und die
kommen auch in das Seminar geht
natürlich Workshops an und mit denen
habe ich schon ein paar Sachen
zusammengearbeitet oder ihn Laufe der
Zeit haben sich das Gute
zusammenarbeiten ergeben würde ich
empfehlen und vielleicht auch der Aufruf
der eigentlich das Kernstück meiner
Präsentation ist würde auch mit Profil
zusammenhängen
vielleicht die Außenperspektive hier ist
der Blick so ein bisschen über den
Tellerrand was machen denn die anderen
wie sieht denn das bei den anderen
erstens hat sich auch auf die Frage
gestellt dürfen die überhaupt uns
bewerten was was machen denn Studierende
wie wie ist das juristisch rechtlich
festgelegt das ist eine Sache die ich
glaube jetzt schon langsam auch durch
ist aber ich finde da noch wichtig auch
das aufzuschreiben oder zumindest zu
verfolgen in der letzten 15 20 Jahren
hat sich viel getan ich finde es gut
dass man sowas natürlich sind manche
Studierende oder auch manche Bewertung
gar nicht so wohl wollen das ist eine
andere Geschichte aber grundsätzlich der
Blick über den Tellerrand ist wirklich
sehr lohnend auch diese Artikel war sehr
sehr zielführend für mich und zu
überlegen okay jetzt weiß ich wie die
Studierenden über mich denken aber wie
würden meine Kollegen die Fachexperten
oder vielleicht auch fachfremd sind
diesen Vortrag oder jeden Vortrag diese
Vorlesung diese Seminar eigentlich
Begutachtung da bin ich auf die Idee
gekommen also ein bisschen noch mal den
Tellerrand ausweitet und weiterhin Weg
guckt man Vergleich sich dann gerne man
liest gerne von Namen hat Universitäten
das Elite und das Wort der
Elite-Universität vielleicht zu sprechen
das ist immer die Frage was man als
Elite empfindet aber man vergleicht sich
dann doch letztendlich gerne wenn man
sich mit Berkley oder auch mit Stan von
Vergleich die machen das die machen
Tatsache diese per Reviews und die
vergleichen unterschiedliche
Strukturen die die Dozierenden anbieten
Professoren Senior Lektor und so weiter
und das fand ich sehr sehr ermutigend
das heißt ich muss keine Angst haben das
was ich will das machen ja auch schon
andere dabei kommt eigentlich gutes raus
die Initialzündung für mich war
eigentlich die Zusammenarbeit mit Profil
und als man dann gesehen hat z.B die der
Bericht der Lehrer warum so wenige
Studierende diese Evaluation Eva System
abgeben und dann habe ich mir die Farbe
warum so schlecht sind wir so schlecht
haben die keine Zeit also nur ein
bisschen auf die Daten wenn 20 oder fast
unter 20% der Studierenden sich an
diesen allsemesterlichen Evaluationen
beteiligen das ist toll das ist super
weil sie ja sozusagen ihre gedank guten
kundtun aber warum so wenige und dann
kann ich auf die Idee na gut vielleicht
sind sie unzufrieden vielleicht ist das
System dass der Bewertung gar nicht so
gut das kann man einfach mit Bleistift
und Papier machen oder modernen mit
diesen Evaluationsbögen grundsätzlich
gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit das zu
bewerten da sieht man die
zufriedenheitsgrade oder die Strukturen
die dann dementsprechend bemängelt
werden oder was auch immer für die
Studierenden gut oder schlecht ist auch
die die Kriterien Evaluation das finde
ich natürlich sehr Lohne sehr sehr sehr
wichtig die Frage ist natürlich immer
die mich ich mir dann gestellt habe wenn
mich die Studierenden so bewerten ich
habe teils in diesen letzten 15 Jahren
meiner Lehre und akademischer Tätigkeit
oder auch übersetzungsfähigkeit in
intensiv in der letzten fünf sechs
Semester und sehr gute Bewertungen aber
nach wie vor ein paar kritische wo ich
danach denken musste woran liegt es dass
es eine begründete oder eine
unbegründete Meinung nicht dass du dort
ich spiele gerne mit meinen Gedanken und
ähm ich empfinde dass wir natürlich auch
als Lehrer Personal
[Musik]
erinnerungswürdig sein können und
verbesserungswillig also wir wollen
etwas dazu lernen egal wie schon gemacht
haben also diese Bewertungen die kennen
wir alle wie gesagt haben ihre
Berechtigung auch das funktioniert in
der Hinsicht gut was ich daraus
natürlich immer wieder rauslesen kann
wie ich mich verbessern kann oder welche
Vorschläge ich machen kann was wirklich
gut was schlecht angekommen sind
angekommen ist aber was ich nicht daraus
sehen kann wie meine Kollegin und
Kolleginnen darüber nachdenken und da
bin ich nachgedacht was in die
Erfolgsfaktoren für gute Lehre was was
bedeutet gute Lehre vielleicht wenn ich
meine Oma zitieren kann zu einer guter
super gehört viel allein und wir wissen
dass viele Faktoren wichtig sind es geht
nicht darum was der eine oder andere
sondern dieses Zusammenspiel von
verschiedenen Faktoren bringt das auch
sind wir auch Rahmenbedingungen in die
erfüllt werden müssen das personelle
also wie ich auftrete und vielleicht
auch die Konstellation der Studierenden
grundsätzlich gibt es hier didaktische
transparente Kriterien und das wäre der
Aufruf für einen Workshop oder die
Diskussionsrunde nach dem Montag dass
man sich überlegt welche sind diese
Kriterien wie erfülle ich diese
Kriterien wäre ich denn bereit mich nach
diesen Kriterien oder anderen die wir
noch aufbauen zu prüfen also dies meine
lehrpilze Persönlichkeit mein
persönlicher Stil zu viel zu wenig reden
Tafelbild manuschelt oder man ist sehr
exaktisch oder man ist irgendwie sehr
demotiviert den eigenen Vortrag zu
halten das sind Kriterien die wir alle
kennen dazu gibt es natürlich auch sehr
viele wirklich gute Bücher die uns allen
bekannt sind oder auch dementsprechend
immer wieder neu entdeckt werden aber
grundsätzlich haben wir auch immer
diesen Faktor X dass wir Fantasie
brauchen dieser Bagger der vielleicht
dann die Landschaft stört und auch eine
vorbereitende Vorlesung oder ein eine
Unterrichtszeit gut vorzubereiten ist
nicht das Problem das haben wir glaube
ich gelernt was ich aber gerne wissen
würde wie erfolgreich ich darin war und
wie sehr ich noch ausbaufähig in meinen
Kriterien bin also in Indien vielleicht
ein kurzer äh eine Abschweifung oder
eine konkret Regierung damit wir aus der
Theorie in die Empirie kommen
Vorlesungen ja interessant wenn man sich
die presse-landschaft anschaut zu den
Vorlesungen was ich sehr viel
geschrieben und sehr kritische Sachen
manche sind gut was machen Studierende
eigentlich während der Vorlesung wie
kann man das Optimieren haben wir schon
gemacht mit Pausen Unterbrechungen
dementsprechend aktiven Fragen aber
grundsätzlich bleibt die Vorlesung in
ihren Charakter so wie sie ist das ist
eine alles vernichtende Frage sind die
Vorlesungen noch zeitgemäß ich würde
sagen ja natürlich aber wir müssen uns
dessen auch bewusst sein dass sie nicht
immer gut funktionieren die
Konstellation nicht immer stimmt und die
Zutaten dazu auch natürlich
passend sein müssen
wie gesagt die Vorlesung als Flaggschiff
der Hochschule ist wahrscheinlich eines
der häufigsten Formen der Lehre wir
hatten sehr feste vielleicht ein
bisschen wie Jack Sparrow mit seiner
black oral hat vor und Nachteile das ist
gar nicht so unumstritten oder wir
wissen dass es so umstritten ist und
dass wir vor und Nachteile haben die
kann man dann aufzählen was wir dann
gerne machen also das von Inhalte
fokussiert dass man sehr Meldung sehr
viele Sachen mit der großes Publikum
grundlegends erreicht hat auch viele
Nachteile interessanterweise haben wir
vielleicht die gleichen Kriterien die
dienen könnten als Vor- und als
Nachteile also man kann in kurzer Zeit
relativ viel sagen und das sind die
Vorlesungen die ich gemacht habe manche
waren sehr gut besucht manche sehr
schlecht und da fragt man sich natürlich
okay was ist das wo ist das Problem
warum hat man so gute in manchen oder
manchen auch schlechten
Zeiten schlechte Besucherzahlen oder
grundsätzlich passive
Studierende was kann man machen
einerseits kann man Befragungen
anstellen befragen lassen sich selbst
befahren lassen das ist interessant wenn
Sie jetzt einfach oder wenn ihr einfach
mal vorstellt die Studierenden würden am
Ende des Semesters ein Katalog stellen
wie die Tübinger Studenten das und das
hat mir gefallen das hat mir Missfallen
dass würde ich ändern das finde ich
eigentlich sehr motivierend und sehr
mutig dass die Studierenden letztendlich
dann sagen wie sie die Bewertung von dem
Professoren sehen das kennen wir auch
das finde ich gut
die Befragungen die dann dementsprechend
weitergehen würde dann nicht dazu
gebracht selber Kriterien auf den wie
bin ich nicht rede ich auf ja nicht
immer einfach ich weiß dass das bei
manchen Missmut erzeugt vielleicht auch
nicht immer verständlich ist das
Spektrum der gute Lehrenden das ist
eigentlich die falsche Folie man kann es
aber auch so verstehen dass es gute und
weniger gute und brauchbares gibt aber
grundsätzlich wären das vielleicht dann
wäre das vielleicht ein Vorschlag dass
man mit desktoren arbeitet und mit
Stufen was ist unverzichtbar für die
gute Lehre was ist wesentlich und was
wäre wünschenswert und da kann man einen
Kriterienkatalog aufbauen diesen
Kriterien Katalog kann man dann frei
definieren und das wäre der Aufrufe auf
Euch alle seit lange in der Lehre manche
vielleicht auch eher kürzer was aber
überhaupt keinen kein Problem darstellt
weil manchmal hat man auch so die eigene
Perspektive nachdem man nicht mehr
rauskommt aber wenn man sich dann
Kriterien Katalog aufstellen und dann
noch jemanden einlädt so eine Art von
hospitierung ich komme zu dir du kommst
zu mir man entwickelt dann so eine
Rotationsprinzip und Versuch auf diese
Kriterien abzugelten und abzuarbeiten
mich würde wirklich interessieren was
dabei rauskommt natürlich was ich jetzt
als unverzichtbar als wesentlich oder
eventuell wünschenswert sehe in der
Lehre
vortragsstilen foliengestaltung Übungen
interaktive Übungen durch mit
Unterbrechungen oder zeitliche
sukzessionen während einer Vorlesung das
ist alles diskutierbar also wir könnten
uns auf das Zeitgefühl oder
Zeitmanagement fokussieren und den
Zeitrahmen einhalten ob das jetzt
unverzichtbar ist oder beim abgestraft
wird oder einfach wesentlich aber
natürlich kennen wir das dass man mal
früher oder mal später vielleicht mit
einem Inhalt nicht kommt nicht drüber
kommt oder ist nicht abschließend
den Studierenden Vortagen kann aber mich
würde interessieren welche Kriterien
grundsätzlich Zeitgefühl oder auch
andere für einen Spektrum meines guten
Lehrenden in einer guten Lehrenden
gelten sollten was ihr da mit meinen ich
hatte einfach eine eigene ergriffen die
hat dann so ausgesprochen die letzten
sieben Semestern habe ich neben der
Evaluation von den
Studierenden auch meine Eigeninitiativen
gemacht das ist nicht immer einfach
manche Sachen sind unangenehm aber
vielleicht so wie Mark Twain gesagt hat
wenn ich es machen soll dann mache ich
es lieber schnell das wäre dann
Kriterien Seminarinhalt Sachwissen und
Organisationsfähigkeit der Dozent selber
als Person und Persönlichkeit Seminar
insgesamt und vielleicht noch
ausgeteilte Material um es vielleicht
ein bisschen zu vergrößern das wäre ein
Kriterien natürlich die abgefragt habe
und die auch dementsprechend
zurückgekommen sind das würde mich
natürlich von den Studierenden
interessieren habe ich es gemacht ich
habe sehr sehr viele in der letzten 87
Semestern alle gesammelt manche Seminare
gut besucht mit 20 30 manche mit sieben
acht deswegen war die hat auch die Zahl
dieser zurückgegebenen Bögen was mich
interessieren würde wie die Studierenden
wie die Professoren die Dozenten meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nicht selbst
erkennen und da habe ich Initiative
gestartet das ist auch normal aus dem
Fragebogen kann man natürlich auch noch
Fragen stellen auch für eine Fragen das
ist jetzt mal eine repräsentative die
ich sehr gut ausgefallen aber ich habe
auch schlechtere die ist natürlich in
diesen Vortrag versteckt aber ich
empfinde mich immer noch als lernwillig
und lernen fähig und ausbaufähig da
frage ich mich was kann man ändern und
damit komme ich auch zu dem Schluss und
zu dem Aufruf ich versuche einen
Workshop zu organisieren indem wir diese
Kriterien besprechen ich habe sehr viel
Gegenwind erfahren als diesen Workshop
geplant habe und auch die Studenten und
die beziehungsweise Professoren manche
so ich lasse mich doch nicht von
irgendjemanden bewerten oder ich bin ja
eigentlich schon lange genug dabei ich
weiß wie es läuft genauso auch viel
Fahrtwind bekommen von einer wirklich
lieben Professorin Kollegin die gesagt
hat ich habe viele Publikationen ich bin
sehr schnell meine Universität Karriere
Professor Berufung alles schnell aber
ich habe nie richtig Didaktik gelernt
ich weiß nicht richtig wie man einen
Vortrag oder wie man eine Folie hat
niemand beigebracht alles learning bei
Dillingen das ist natürlich toll aber
wenn jemand auch offen war ich weiß
etwas nicht genau gut oder nicht richtig
oder nicht ich glaube vielleicht könnte
man es verbessern und hat mir doch Mut
gegeben also ihr seht es ich suche nach
Kriterien die die Qualität der Lehre
verbessern könnten ich habe sehr guten
Kontakt mit Michael Rödel in der
Didaktik und mit Harald Lesch und wir
haben schon einige
Strukturen und einige Seminare und
einige Workshop aufgebaut gerade der
letzte war der Perspektive zu lehren
lohnt es sich noch in die Wissenschaft
zu gehen mit Harald Wäsche hat
zugesichert wenn wir einen Workshop
aufbauen in diesem Rahmen wollen was ist
ein guter Dozent ein guter Professor was
bedeutet das eigentlich welche Kriterien
und die Evaluationen dass wir mal
untereinander ein selbstrevolution ist
natürlich wichtig aber das Stichwort für
heute wäre
Pinguin einen kollegiales
Rotationsprinzip dass diejenigen die
halt bewertet werden die gehen an die
Mitte und wenn sie sich aufgewärmt haben
dann gehen sie raus und diejenigen die
draußen gestanden haben die gehen dann
rein wer wäre denn bereit in meinem
Vorlesung zu kommen meine vorlesungs Art
und Weise abzuklopfen nach diesen
Kriterien die wir stehen wäre jemand
bereit sich dann auch anzumelden dass
ich zu ihm gehe oder drei vier Leute
sich dann dementsprechend sich das
anschauen und bewerten wie gut bin ich
und ich finde nur durch austauschte
Revision dieser Kriterien kann
eigentlich nichts Falsches entstehen
immer nur Zumutung dass man vielleicht
nicht der beste oder nicht die beste ist
aber darum geht es nicht es geht darum
dass man das was man macht was man
wirklich leidenschaftlich war auch
vielleicht wirklich gut kann noch besser
kann daher dazu in diesem Sinne nicht
bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit und
jetzt zeigt danke schön